Okay.
All right, welcome everyone to the
Active Inference Institute's tech
textbook reading group. We're going over
the the new recent publication
Fundamentals of Active Inference by
Sanjeev Namjoshi, who's put
at least a solid couple of years into
this textbook and previously was doing
feedback sessions with a lot of
Institute members as well during
a lot of the initial rough draftings
period and so it's it's been really
great to be able to see this textbook
kind of come to full fruition upon his
publication and we've all been very
excited to start teaching it.
Um
and so um
there are three of us who have been
facilitating these sessions. Although I
will say right now at the at the outset
and I I I do say this with some
disappointment, but there have been some
kind of rescheduling movements made. So
unfortunately, this particular Thursday
session, which is more or less the
evening time in the Western Hemisphere,
will no longer be be offered by the
Institute following this week. We do
apologize for any kind of inconvenience
that that presents anyone who cannot
necessarily make the other two sessions,
but all of the sessions are recorded. Um
we still have the coda page here
from sharing my screen.
So we we do record all of them and they
all can be found on the meetings page.
And so for anyone who wants to
asynchronously follow along, we
obviously also would welcome anyone to
start their own subgroups or otherwise
or even make it a part of the Institute
if they would maybe like to host their
own sort of session around this
textbook. The main thing was just we're
we're sort of reorganizing the resources
and and time we have available. And so
there are there are many aspects to
teaching this textbook
this year. First, of course, it's our
first time doing it. We're all sort of
getting a a grasp of it. Second, this
textbook, unlike the previous 2022
textbook that we've hosted sessions
around, this textbook will actually have
various like coding and programming
examples that will be
released for anyone to try or test or
adapt to their own use cases. And and
so, not all of that has been released
just yet because, unfortunately, it's
not been entirely finalized upon the
publication of this book,
but we will be essentially assisting
Sanjeev with the process of building out
that code.
And so, part of the movement here to
cancel these Thursday sessions is so
that I can better assist with that as
well as make sure the other two sessions
will go smoothly. So, I'll actually be
present at the other sessions very
frequently. So, all of that said,
you know, welcome back. I you know, I've
noticed a couple familiar names here.
And
so, today we were going to go over
chapter one as well as appendix A.
Of course, appendix A is not necessarily
you know, something that you have to
jump to and immediately comprehend and
study inside and out as we're just
beginning the textbook reading group.
But the the main purpose of including it
is simply that one is very much
a kind of introductory chapter.
We're not quite hit with all of the
mathematical formalisms yet that we'll
start seeing later.
And it also gives a nice kind of concise
history of active inference. And it sort
of sort of placement in the general
scientific historical trajectory here.
So, I just wanted to kind of point out
um yeah, you you can see that many of
these these notions kind of start
roughly in the '90s. Of course, arguably
many ideas that go into active inference
come much, you know, more prior to that.
We have Helmholtz in in the 19th century
on the notion of unconscious inference
and different kinds of perceptual
processes happening in the brain
regardless of our awareness of it and
trying to understand the brain as, you
know, sort of um
a kind of adaptive organism or or or set
of organisms if you look at it as
different regions in the brain
and and many other kind of like
different perspectives on that. And so,
at least by 1990, we end up with a lot
of this these kind of coming together of
like what is perception, what are
representations in the brain. Those who
have studied kind of William James in
sort of will be very familiar with you
know, what what does it mean for the
brain to sort of represent
information
and
and then at the same time we have this
growth of like Bayesian frameworks for
for statistical modeling.
We have variational Bayesian methods
that are used for overcoming different
kinds of otherwise intractable problems.
And so, being able to use Bayes
plus approximation to confront different
kinds of problems. We have the Rao and
Ballard predictive coding which is very
strongly in certain ways influential
in in the active inference area.
Many of you have probably seen this
phrase predictive coding before.
Of course,
predictive being a key aspect of that
and that perception can be related to
the idea of predicting.
It's not simply in and out, it's also
what what happens next. Or given some
kind of sensory data, what do I think is
going on in the world? Uh what are what
are the hidden states of of the world
that I can't necessarily see, but what I
can see might inform me of those things.
Um with that, we have the Bayesian brain
hypothesis, which I think is in some
ways kind of summarized by my
immediately preceding example that
perhaps the the brain the human brain or
any living organism's brain uh does
something like Bayesian inference. Um
and then all the while, of course, we
have this like strong growth in
different kinds of neuroimaging methods
and techniques. And that leads on to
uh many more further uh thereafter. Uh
we know that um um Friston and many of
his colleagues are responsible for doing
things like building out the uh SPM sta-
statistical parametric mapping library
and MATLAB, um building out methods like
dynamic causal modeling for
understanding uh neuroimaging data as uh
kind of like using that data and
relating it to a model to get at some of
these sort of um
inference uh frameworks that I mentioned
earlier, the idea of inferring um
hidden causes from data. In this case,
we're looking at brain data and what
what that brain data aligns with or what
it means. You know, is there some
particular behavior or some particular
pattern going on in the brain that this
this uh EEG or fMRI data we're seeing
like corresponds to or relates to? Uh
that is, what's going on in the brain
that causes the kinds of fluctuations
that we see in the neuroimaging data
that we're collecting. Um and so
I put together just this few slides uh
slideshow because I just wanted to um
point out a couple of things for those
who might be less familiar with with uh,
the mathematics, with thinking about
Bayes, um, with what is a random
variable, just th- those sorts of
things. But of course, like if you're
interested in this textbook and you've
noticed the subtitle includes
uh, the word engineers and uh, and
algorithms and so on in it, you you you
probably have some kind of familiar
familiarity. So I won't dedicate too
much time to this, but um, so chapter
one, which we've also read, gets into
this notion of something like a
hypothesis testing brain.
Uh, again, there's the Bayesian uh,
brain hypothesis. There's a more uh,
general blanket term known as um,
predictive processing. It's not the same
as predictive coding. In some ways,
predictive coding is a sort of
particular case of predictive
processing. Um, but predictive
processing being that, you know, the
brain kind of um,
you you come to a situation uh, with
your own
I hesitate to say prior knowledge cuz it
doesn't necessarily have to follow a
Bayesian framework. That's why it's such
a big blanket term. But it's that uh,
you know, the the the brain sort of
superimposes in some ways what it's
learned before onto how it understands
the world now.
Uh, right? So it's it's not purely that
the brain is always and forever
uh, only a passive observer taking in
what it sees uh, and mapping it and
there's no relation to the to the past.
There's there's a kind of predictive
element. Um, and and that bears out
really well as far as neuroimaging
studies of perception go. In fact, some
studies find that we're always kind of
uh,
the conception of now is that we're
always sort of blending together what
just happened immediately prior to now
and what we think is going to come next.
Right? So um, Um, but I'll I'll slow on
the abstractness. It's just to say that
um, we have this kind of hypothesis
testing brain notion that the the the
brain
again doesn't passively take in
information and that's it. It's that it
it it can hold potentially different
kinds of representations. It can
potentially choose between different
representations like hypotheses about
the world um, in the in the Bayesian
inference kind of scheme. We're able to
entertain multiple hypotheses and kind
of assign we can kind of weight them one
against another. Uh, so one of them has
a higher likelihood or
higher probability of being true uh, as
opposed to another hypothesis
uh, or or otherwise. And
um,
for those who are interested more
uh, explicitly in the engineering side
um, a lot of these things that I've been
discussing strongly align with different
kinds of advances and changes in
frameworks that we see in uh, sort of
modern machine and deep and
reinforcement learning methods. So I
notions of perception in some ways are
kind of like just given some data, what
is your prediction? So whenever we
interact with a an LLM chat chat GPT or
something like that in some ways it
might be related to a notion of
perception. Like given this prompt that
I input to the model, what does the
model predict it should say in response?
Um, right? So we've not quite gotten
into action. We've not quite gotten into
planning there yet. Um, so it's it's
good to keep these terms a little bit
separate, be aware of their their
particular nuances, but at least
perception being okay, we have we have
we have observations, we have we have
states. We have the prompt and we we
have the response. Um, that's one way of
thinking about those sorts of things.
You can equivalently think about that
whenever you're looking at, you know,
financial data. Like given something
happened in the world, what is the
chance that, you know, that the stock
price will fluctuate or that it will go
in a particular direction as opposed to
another.
So, all of this is relevant to
engineering, of course, as well.
And so, so a lot there's a lot of
overlap between these different things.
And then, I wanted to highlight why
we're doing Bayesian inference
and why this book starts moving that
direction. And there's going to be
plenty of reason to see that as we
proceed into further chapters after
chapter 1.
But it's just to say cuz chapter 1
itself has this whole section on what
they call the inverse problem. And it's
a very good it's a very interesting way
of of looking at problems in general
that that relate to perception, to
action, to relating data with with
different kinds of hidden states or
causes,
which is that whenever
we
I I included this image of a
this kind of classic optical illusion
image where
people will debate if it looks more like
a rabbit or if it looks like a duck,
right? It's there that given this one
piece of sensory information that we
received, which is this one picture, you
know, why does it look like that? Is it
because it's a duck or is it because
it's a rabbit? And so, it's just to
highlight that you can have these
problems where there's kind of
one-to-many or many-to-one
relationships. And so, whenever we try
to just use like a much more kind of
classical
model to try and explain that where it's
like, "Oh, well, it, you know, it has,
you know, this part over here is a beak,
right? So, it must be a duck." But it's
like, "No, that part over there actually
looks like ears, right?" So, we we
continue with this kind of one-to-many,
many-to-one kind of mapping, and then
suddenly, uh
you know, if you're just, in a classical
kind of situation, you're you're forced
to choose one. So, if you if you make a
model, if you make a a reinforcement
learning model for a robot that's
supposed to be able to navigate a
warehouse and do different kinds of
things, and it's confronted with all of
these kind of difficult problems that
have one-to-many or many-to-one
mappings, where you know that the
consequences of the actions it chooses
could actually
have high stakes for for the situation
that it's in, you know, it could end up,
you know, accidentally breaking things
because it made the wrong movement,
because it could not kind of it couldn't
kind of weigh its options out, and it
couldn't like kind of recognize that
there is uncertainty in this situation,
and it had no way of falling back to any
kind of prior knowledge or information,
because it's simply if this, then that,
right? Like, you know, if it looks like
this, it must be a duck, or if it looks
like this, it must be a rabbit. Instead,
the Bayesian framework allows for kind
of bringing one's own prior knowledge to
the table, and so we have this, I put in
down here for priors, like, "Clearly,
it's a duck," said the person who'd
never seen a rabbit before, right? It's
like, based upon what you know when you
come to a situation that can certainly
bias how you interpret the data. It's
not simply a mapping of of data to
states, but you can have your own prior
beliefs about what those states should
be,
and that could allow for a certain kind
of regularization
of one's beliefs. It can allow for a
kind of stabilization,
right?
Just because it becomes dark outside for
a moment does not necessarily mean that
it's now night time, right? It might
just be that a cloud passed by overhead,
and you know, with your prior
information,
oh no, it's it's probably still daytime.
That that's just a momentary
fluctuation, right? Um and so the
Bayesian framework is is relatively
robust to to rapid changes in an
environment. And and that that for those
who are interested in in living beings'
behavior or human behavior or behavior
in the brain, you can imagine like it's
actually very important to be able to
have some sense of stability, some sense
of continuity, to be able to continue
making predictions by being able to
reuse information from the past. Um
and so in some ways it's kind of how
your prior functions in addition to
being able to do the perceptual mapping.
Um
And so another thing that will come up
many times in this textbook that I don't
think is very clearly stated in the
outset is the difference between um
uh continuous and discrete variables.
And and these kinds of um different ways
that active inference is applied between
uh uh these two different kinds of
variables. It
There are enough examples in the
textbook to where you'd certainly intuit
like more specifically what they are.
Uh but I just want to say more plainly
and actually I'll jump ahead.
Uh
On the left-hand side is an example of a
discrete variable
uh in this left-hand plot. And then on
the right is a continuous variable. For
the left, uh the discrete variable, uh
essentially this example is a variable
uh this could be your prior, for
example, if you're setting up like a you
know, a model. Um this could be a prior
over in this example uh the the state of
the weather. So a kind of hidden state
of the weather. Is it sunny? Is it
cloudy? Or is it raining? And we're just
going to assume that those are three
mutually exclusive things. It can only
be one and neither of the the other,
similar to the rabbit versus the the
duck problem earlier. Um and so, what we
can do is kind of represent this as they
all have their own probabilities. So, if
it's a prior, you're that that would be
saying like, "Oh, I I think there's a at
least a you know, there's a a roughly a
50% chance uh that it's sunny outside."
Um much lesser chance that it's cloudy,
even less so that it's raining. And so,
we call that a categorical probability
distribution.
Um and so, in a sense, it's like a set
of beliefs about the state of the
weather, and you can actually evaluate
one against another because they all
have their own respective value.
Um and then furthermore, in future in
like chapter three, we'll see more about
learning in these models. Um there
there's something called a conjugate
prior distribution, the Dirichlet
distribution, and that is uh
structurally kind of equivalent to a
categorical probability distribution,
but it doesn't have to sum to one.
And the the significance of that is that
through [snorts] gaining more
experience, uh you know, seeing more
times that it's been sunny rather than
cloudy, that might start to bias your
beliefs even further and through
accumulation. So, there's just many more
times that I've seen it sunny than
cloudy or rainy, and so eventually, like
this starts to become much stronger. We
renormalize it, and then it once again
becomes a categorical probability
distribution. I've already said a little
bit more than what I needed to, so I'll
move on from that, but um with the the
continuous variable meanwhile, we can
think of things like, you know, what's
the temperature, what time is it, how
much does someone weigh, how much money
do you have? Um these are things that
are not mutually exclusive from one
another necessarily, and not not in the
same sense that we have sunny, cloudy,
or rainy, right? Uh instead, it's kind
of like we we tend to see continuous
variables as something that might be on
a you know, a broad number line uh to
put it that way. And then, I
specifically chose uh one way of like
using a distribution represent um uh a
continuous variable is uh this classic
bell-shaped curve that's known as a
normal distribution. It's kind of fancy
in to represent that cuz there's a lot
of notation in this textbook that uh
sometimes uh it's overlooked that maybe
it needs to be described, too. So,
that's another purpose for these slides.
Um
the the thing about why I chose this one
is that um we're going to see normal
distributions very regularly in this
textbook uh especially in the places
that where we're you know, you see that
there are many chapters that are purely
dedicated to continuous uh problems
rather than discrete ones than chapters
that are dedicated to discrete rather
than continuous. Um for the normal
distribution, there's a specific uh
case, a special case of the normal
distribution called a Gaussian
distribution, and it it is essentially a
normal distribution
and it ha- it takes what are called
parameters. Each model has its own
parameters, which are kind of like
different you almost think of them as
like uh adjustable knobs or something
like that within a model. Um then, those
knobs might you know, go up or they
might go down or there might be some
other kind of um change in them
depending on on what the what exactly uh
the the kind of parameter is. Uh but, a
normal distribution simply has um what
is called a a mean and a variance. Those
are its only two parameters. Those who
are familiar with statistics are going
to get that immediately. Um even those
without knowledge of statistics, uh
generally, it's just the mean is
something like the average. Like on
average, what value does this random
variable tend to take? Uh a Gaussian
would say, oh typically it takes zero.
Uh usually whenever we see this, it's a
zero. So, if you're
um you know, if you if you have a um
uh let's say uh a thermometer
and you you could say like, oh with that
therm thermometer, you know, in my home,
where my home, you know, it's it's it's
temperature doesn't fluctuate too much,
but it fluctuates sometimes. So, at
different times, we could just look at
the values that that thermometer gives,
and then that would allow us to start
kind of approximating a distribution
that pretty well describes the values
that that thermometer usually shows, and
it would probably have a mean,
and then it would also have a variance.
And the variance is just kind of like
how distributed is it around the mean.
If your variance is very very small,
then that means everything's really
going to be concentrated probably around
the mean. Um and if your variance is
very high, then that means things are
going to be very spread out around the
mean. Um and so, Gaussians come up a lot
given that a few special properties that
they kind of have. They're very useful
for for modeling. They come up um
specially already in chapter two, which
I've not made slides for because we're
not there yet. Um
So, in any case, that that's that's
essentially what I wanted to I think
cover here. Um there there's a little
bit more in this slide regarding um sort
of the inverse problem. It's just again
like, what what justifies using a
Bayesian approach as opposed to other
approaches? There are many people who
who are studying reinforcement learning
or otherwise, or there are those who are
in computational neuroscience who want
to know like, why do you want to use a
Bayesian framework rather than more
classical statistical approaches? So, of
course, classical statistical approaches
are what we're most commonly um taught
in many um
university courses and and and Bayes has
always been sort of this this growing
subtopic that you sort of choose to or
not to study along the way.
So, it's just to say that it allows for
actually taking uncertainty into account
rather than sort of getting rid of it
through a more deterministic one-to-one
mapping between what a
a cause
and a and an observation mean in
relation to each other, right? So, I
mean if these things have very high
stakes. If my stomach starts growling, I
might infer that I'm hungry. But if my
stomach starts growling and it's
painful, I might start thinking, "Oh,
no, maybe I have food poisoning." Like
there are very different stakes to those
two different inferences that I could
make. And so, being able to like really
well understand the observations I I
take in and how I evaluate them become
incredibly important. I know that
there's some here who have been
interested in the topic of computational
psychiatry as well. So, we could start
talking about things like false
inference and situation I mean what
happens whenever this prior that earlier
I said helps for
you know, allowing for a certain kind of
stability in one's beliefs, especially
whenever an environment is volatile. It
allows for this you know, kind of
you know, what what what should things
be whenever my whenever my observations
aren't so clear or whenever my vision is
blurry or whenever that cloud passes by
overhead and for a second makes me think
that
you know, it's suddenly night time when
it really isn't.
But but what happens whenever those
priors themselves have certain kinds of
you know, some
certain characteristics about them that
aren't necessarily helpful in the
current situation. Like you know,
someone who has perhaps been in some
kind of car accident and and there's
unfortunately been some sort of you know
something like
we might call trauma or otherwise and
they find themselves needing to get into
a car to go to an event or to go to
their occupation to work or to you know
a variety of other things and suddenly
you know something has happened and
they're learning to where their prior
tells them oh no I shouldn't get in this
car cars are dangerous like there's a
prior belief that cars are dangerous and
then one
then infers further like I shouldn't get
in this car right so it's not to say
that priors are some universally good
thing it's more so that it's sort of
through through the research and through
this kind of nice
confluence of of different fields and
different frameworks and perspectives
many of which are not even represented
here
I haven't brought up anything like
cybernetics I haven't brought up um
studies of agents and environments just
yet I haven't talked about
you know
brief mentions of psychology of of
computational psychiatry and and health
research and all the rest so
yeah it's it's it's been a long kind of
coming together of these different
fields and that's sort of what part of
what brought me to active inference was
sort of the
the deep and broad interdisciplinary
that that it entails
I it's just like it allowed me to sort
of synchronize a lot of my varied
interests cuz I'd always been looking
for a framework to sort of combine them
and and I think this this so far is kind
of been the framework I've I've found
most appealing and that makes most sense
so
um
in any case I will I will sort of stop
there with with this sort of one-way
presentation that I've been giving so
far and
I just wanted to again remind folks that
we do have the coda so again this
particular meeting will be recorded
Daniel gave gave a a really nice
session. He talked about a lot of things
that I myself did not even get through
just now. Uh you know, it's much more
about the Ballard predictive coding
framework. You you know, various other
things. So, very much worth watching
tomorrow
morning. Uh Fraser will also be giving
another session. And then we'll we'll
actually be spending two weeks on each
chapter going forward. And I think that
will allow for a lot more time for
people to sort of digest the material,
to have the opportunity or have two
opportunities to ask questions in the
meetings and sort of have them answered
or discussed. Uh and then it'll allow us
more time to sort of build out the
different kinds of questions that
uh are going to be slowly accumulating
in the in the coda that people can, you
know, discuss or give a give a thumbs up
if they find equal interest to to more
uh improve the probability that those
questions will be be answered. Um so,
uh so, I would just kind of like to open
the floor a little bit. Uh is is there
anything that anyone read that um you
know, was interesting to them or any
other kinds of thoughts or impressions
from from the the reading for today or
for last week or anyone who's new who'd
like to introduce themself, please feel
free.
Yeah.
Mark, yeah. Please go for it.
Let me jump in since nobody else did.
Nice job going Thank you for going over
uh some of the particulars that I think
that the the book does assume assume we
know. Um
Yeah, I didn't see the engineer in the
title in the small print when I ordered
the book. So, it's a good thing I
didn't. So.
>> [laughter]
>> But I think the book does do a good job
overall. It is clear. But I think thanks
for addressing those nuances there.
You can tell me if we can save this, but
I just thought I'd just jump in
just based on a curiosity. You put up
the Gaussian curve there. And you talked
about
variance and
with the inverse of the variance being
precision, right? And and in active
inference we often think of
uh
precision as attention,
right? And I I've
I'm having a hard time wrapping my head
around that because this seems to be
kind of like the signal, right? So, if
the signal is very precise, or maybe I'm
misconstruing it, but if the signal is
very precise,
that does not that seems like a
bottom-up
sort of reference to something that I
would consider as attention being
top-down. So, is it that I'm more likely
to pay attention to it if it's a precise
signal?
Um since we do seem to in active
inference talk about precision mapping
to attention.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's a good No, that's a
that's a great question.
I'll I'll try and like kind of
procedurally approach it.
So, first, yes. So, if you took the
inverse here and you sort of flipped it,
let's just pretend that the inverse
wasn't one. Let's pretend it's two.
So, now the
the Excuse me, I don't know how I said
that. Let's pretend the variance is two.
So, if we flipped it, it becomes 1/2.
And and that 1/2 is now the precision,
exactly as you said, as opposed to being
the variance. Um, the whole point of
that is that since you see that they're
just sort of the reciprocal of each
other, the whole point is if the if the
variance, as it is, is very high, right?
That means the probability is going to
be very spread out. Um, whereas if the
variance is very low, which also means
the the precision will go up because
they're just the reciprocal of each
other,
um, then uh, the the probability will be
concentrated most especially around a
very particular value. Um, so you can
think of it like I mentioned a
thermometer earlier. Or like a, you
know, let's let's say that I'm looking
at the thermostat in my apartment and
I'm convinced over the years that it is
just an awful thermostat. It is so bad
at telling the temperature. Sometimes
it's it's I'm sweating in here and yet
it says it's, you know, um, 50° inside
or something. So I don't really trust
this thermometer very much.
If I could take my beliefs about how
well my thermometer works, like my
beliefs about how accurate it is and try
and kind of put them on on a spread of a
a distribution like this, it would have
very high variance, right? Like the
the temperature is just kind of all over
the place. It's not very It's not very
precise. It's not very It doesn't very
well align with an actual particular
state of my apartment. Like sometimes it
shows a value that normally would mean
it's hot, but actually in here I think
it's cold and it feels very cold. And so
you end up with that kind of
one to many or many to one mapping, uh,
that I kind of was trying to get out
with this whole duck and the rabbit
problem, uh, right? It's like, well,
my thermostat says it's this, but
honestly it could be anything at this
point until I like just feel for myself
because I don't trust this thing. So to
to get back to your question,
um, um
whenever precision is much higher, we
could almost say that it's kind of like
my confidence in my beliefs about this
information that I'm seeing and what it
really means. Uh so, if the the
precision's very high, that means the
variance is very low. It just means that
I can make a much more if
I have a kind of confidence about what
this means and and not only that, but if
I can confidently rely upon it, then the
next step would be able to say like, oh,
I if I can confidently rely upon this, I
might be willing to pay attention to it.
Whereas, if I for my thermostat that is
clearly messed up, uh I don't trust it,
right? I don't feel confident about what
it says and what it's saying, if it
actually reflects the real state of the
environment around me, if it's, you
know, if it's too high, but actually
it's cold in here or vice versa. Um it's
a it's a many-to-one problem, and and so
then the variance is very high, the
precision is very low. I'm going to
trust it less, and so consequently, I
probably will pay less attention to it.
Someone will come in here and say like,
oh, it's cold. Like, what what's going
on with the thermostat? I'll say, no,
don't pay attention to that thing, it's
broken, right? Um so, I'm I I don't mean
to like kind of make these like it's
such a simple like kind of almost silly
example, but I think it's uh it is one
way of sort of getting at that problem,
because yeah, precision will definitely
come up much more uh in the textbook
later, and you can see on sort of the
the behavioral front or the the sort of
psychological front, precision does kind
of align with this notion of and that
that that confidence is not purely
uh you know, a feeling. Uh here, we're
looking at models, and so that
confidence is really saying, oh, I'm
sure that this means this and doesn't
mean that." Um
so so whenever it comes to like
deliberate decision-making in a person,
you know, we tend to think of someone
who's confident is like, "Oh, they know
what to do." Right? So that's sort of a
more everyday way of trying to to be
able to say like
they're they're very confident. They
have very high precision in their
beliefs. They have very low variance in
their beliefs. They they have a pretty
strong idea of how things work and what
to do about it. Um
So I yeah, I hope that was I hope that
was helpful in some way.
>> That's excellent. And and the the
example you just gave uh makes me think
of someone with a with a really precise
prior belief, whereas uh this could uh
pertain to to either. Is that right?
Could could be I so in in terms of
either, I guess I should specify that
we're talking about uh either component
of the model where it's the
where it's either prior or likelihood.
Is that Is that right? With the with the
former being more of the top-down as you
described and the and the
uh the latter being more of the
bottom-up, which would be to your
thermostat example, right? So
Yeah.
>> So so that's very that's very good. Can
I just ask one quick follow-up and then
I'll I'll mute myself since it's very
related. Um
This is not noise. Is that right? This
is
This this is different than noise.
Uh
It's a bit tricky. Um but I would say So
yeah, because it's there's the there's
like very precise ways of using these
terms and then there's a bit more um
you know, looser ways of using these
terms. And I I am trying to use them in
the more precise ways. Um but the the
looser ways are sometimes useful uh in
the way that you can use them more like
a metaphor that does genuinely imply. Uh
it's just maybe not exactly how that
word is used. But here you could say you
could say that there's noise whenever
there's very high variance.
Which necessarily, you know, it's the
reciprocal, so that means there's very
low precision.
In that case, you could say that you
expect this to be
a very high noise kind of model, right?
Like there's a lot of noise going on in
my broken thermostat, right? Like 1
second it says it's 80° and the next it
says it's 52 and I have no idea what's
going on. It's a you know, you could
view it as a very noisy kind of process
or or or a very noisy set of of obser-
observations that it's generating for me
to see, right? So so you could very much
use the word noise in that kind of
context. And then I like I I like how
you phrased that regarding the priors
versus the likelihood. The priors are
sort of what you bring to the situation.
And so if you have very precise priors,
that could look like that
very confident person I mentioned a
moment ago who's feels very sure that
they know what to do and how to go about
it
before they even come into the
situation, right? This is their prior
knowledge about things and how the world
works.
But of course, if those priors are very
precise and something changes like oh, I
thought I knew what to do, but then
actually
you know, the the bus was running behind
and and I had my whole day planned out
around that bus being on time and now
that it's running way behind, it's
offset everything else. Oh no, what do I
do?
It's like well, I didn't take any time
to consider in advance what, you know,
contingency plans. I didn't allow for
anything like that. I would my beliefs
were very precise, so precise that I
just assumed that bus would be on time
as well.
You know, so that that that can be the
trouble of having high precision
beliefs,
right? Or or I brought up my stomach
growling earlier. Like that means I'm
hungry. It only ever means I'm hungry,
right? That would be a very precise
belief to have. And so next thing I
know, I start having some kind of issue.
I wind up at the doctor. They say,
"Well, why didn't you come in? You're
having all these issues." I'm like,
"Well, I'm convinced that it means I'm
hungry." And then it turns out I have a
a sto- a stomach ulcer or something and
and just didn't allow for that because
of the precision of my beliefs. Um So
yeah, it is a very is the prior is very
much kind of like a bottom-down process,
um which whenever it comes to the the
kind of more neuroscientific stance on
it is that it's something that you've
kind of accumulated over time and that
you you've learned through experience
and being taught different kinds of
things. That's sort of what composes
your priors.
And and and so it's important to have a
sort of implicit balancing between the
prior and the likelihood cuz the
likelihood is also in many ways
uh
it is kind of like a bottom-up process,
right? Cuz it's mapping observations to
hidden states. So it's actually saying,
"Oh no, I need to take in sensory
information. I need to take it I need to
be open enough to the world to take in
this information so that I can update my
beliefs, right?" Um and that's sort of
what the whole um Bayesian scheme
uh at least on the face of it is is
about. And so let me just um
Yeah, classic uh
Oh.
Not the prettiest. Um yeah, so this is
Bayes' theorem. And so it's like we're
combining our likelihood of how
observations relate to states
with our prior, which is just our a
priori beliefs about states.
Um and then the way that you then
resolve that to update your beliefs is
that you just kind of take those, you
multiply them together, you divide by
model evidence, which is
something like a prior on observations.
It results in your posterior.
Um chapter one doesn't I think it gives
some more everyday kind of examples of
that, but it's it's essentially like the
main point still stands. Like you you
have your prior and you have your
likelihood. You have top-down and you
have bottom-up. There's this kind of
interaction between them going on. So.
Um yeah, I I really appreciate the the
questions, Mark. Those are those are the
right kind of questions to to be asking,
I think, in my opinion.
>> Thank you. Thank you very much.
So.
Yeah.
Um does anyone else have
any other thoughts or or things that
they've been it's kind of been on their
mind as they work their way through this
textbook?
Yeah, well, anyone feel free to to raise
your hand going forward if anything
comes up. Um Daniel has sort of
encouraged us to look at the other
questions that people have started
asking um already about the textbook.
And so, I'll just give a couple of those
a shot. Um
let's see. I really like some of these
in particular. Can the environment also
include other potential agents then the
external states would be internal states
of other agents. Um
I'm going to refrain from like typing in
an answer to that in this moment, but uh
So, if you yourself are an agent and in
an environment, um and let me just see
if I can find an appropriate figure to
get at that.
I'm just
certain that there's one in here.
Yeah. So, we have the agent, then we
have the environment. Uh this is the the
third figure in chapter one.
Um
and and we're introduced to this notion
of a Markov blanket. And we'll we'll
hold off for the immediate moment on,
you know, why [clears throat] Markov,
why blanket, why
why any of that? What's what's that
about? Um we're just going to talk about
a very general notion of um
So, I'm someone who comes from this uh
more like social sciences background and
then took a rather eclectic turn towards
sort of like data science and
engineering and and now here I am and
doing work in uh computational
psychiatry and and other areas, but um
but from the social science perspective,
it was always very important for us to
be able to delimit Now, social science
meaning we're we're not just studying a
single agent, we're studying many
agents. Um
and many people, like people in a
society or or a a country or some kind
of collective. And we're look we might
be looking at things like individual
behavior, at collective behavior. We
might break it up into different scales,
where it's like, okay, well, you have um
the entire country of the United States,
and then it itself is composed of 50
different states, and then each of those
states has cities. And so, we start
looking at things at different kind of
scales. Um
and and different populations within
populations, and so on. You could break
things up demographically or otherwise,
but always because you're not able
whenever you do that kind of research,
you're typically not able to to log
every single precise detail about every
single individual person, there's some
kind of degree of abstraction going on
where you kind of have to you do have to
kind of delimit it or define the
boundaries uh between like what what is
the society you're looking at and what
is not the society that you're looking
at or or if you're going to break it up
into intermediate groups in the middle,
like well, how are they separate from
one another?
And then if you take a very different
approach uh as opposed to the social
sciences is if you look at it more from
like a sort of um
you know, a kind of uh physics-oriented
level and you're thinking about like
what is it what is a thing and what
differentiates it from other things, you
could kind of try and drill all the way
down. Well, a person is just a a
collection of different organs. The skin
is an organ. Like it's
it's just a bunch of different parts and
then well, it's like, okay, well, but
then further you could go you know, down
and down and down we get to cells, we
get all the way down to to particles, we
get down to electrons and so on uh the
quarks if you like. And so at what point
do we do we stop with that? At what
point do we need to scale back up? And a
lot of it has to do with well, what what
is it that you're trying to understand?
What is it that you're trying to to make
sense of or analyze? And in this context
of like engineering in the context of
working with things like statistics or
statistical mechanics or working up to
to kind of Bayesian mechanics that are
implicated in this textbook and that
Sanjeev is um
writing sort of his volume two will be
entitled Bayesian mechanics. Um
like what we're doing is that we're
we're modeling
uh we're modeling the thing that we're
interested in so that we can understand
it. Um in that case, we do need to be
able to clearly define what it is and
what it isn't. And then, it's sort of
like what it isn't becomes the
environment. So, the environment
in the abstract is everything that is
not our agent. Um, and then, how do we
decide that, right? Like, I while I'm
breathing in air from the I'm breathing
in oxygen from the environment around
me, and now that's become a part of me,
hasn't it? So, what what Did something
change? Is it, you know, did I take
something from the environment make it
part of me as an agent now, or you know,
I exhale CO2, and so is that now no
longer, you know, so we we can do that.
Um,
the main thing is to try and have a a
principled approach to being able to
define what an agent is, so that you can
kind of maintain a sort of coherence in
your your analysis, knowing that the
boundary is very well could change,
right? Um, I mean,
from one standpoint, uh,
whenever someone like kind of kind of
dies, and they no longer has a
uh, you know, agency over their own
body, we might not call them an agent
anymore.
Um, now they've sort of succumbed to
entropy, to the dissipative forces
around them. They've They've They've
become the environment, or part of the
environment. Um, and uh, and and so, um,
it it it it becomes tricky, but it you
see how important it becomes to be able
to sort of delimit things. And so, why a
Markov blanket? Uh, the idea of the the
blanket is that if you can sort of map
the and I'm going to use like slightly
more mathematical language here, but if
you can map the the inputs to the agent,
and you can map the outputs from the
agent,
and you're able to say like, okay, well,
the agent it its inputs are the sensory
information that it receives. It's the
observations it receives, right? Those
come from the environment. And my even
even my stomach growling is is a part of
me, but we but in active inference we
would call that an interoceptive
observation. It's still an observation
I'm receiving. Uh for you know, and so
I'm also receiving you know other kinds
of information. I'm seeing people around
me and right now I'm looking at my
computer screen they're varying levels
of brightness you know coming out of my
screen and other sensations. So I'm able
if we're able to say like here here all
the different kinds of observations I
can receive the interoceptive ones the
exteroceptive ones from the outside
proprioceptive ones that have to do with
my ability to kind of kind of observe my
my motor movement. Those who kind of
work in in um
um you know areas that pertain to to
bodies and and movement athletics or
otherwise you're going to be familiar
with proprioception.
If we can kind of figure out what are
those kinds of observations that one can
receive and we can also look at what
kind of actions can one do to impact the
environment. Then we call those blanket
states. We have sensory states that are
blanket states and we have these kind of
active or control states and that
reduces down to simply saying we have
observations and we have actions. As
long as we can say what those are then
then everything else is either internal
to the agent or external to the agent.
So relative to the agent everything
outside of them is external. So the
um and so the agent kind of its its
internal states are sort of
sort of in certain ways emulating or
trying to model the external states
which is really important. Like it's
important for me to know what the
temperature in my room is so that I can
persist, especially during seasonal
changes. It's important for me to know
that my thermostat is broken that I
shouldn't rely on it and I should look
at, you know, something else or maybe
even better get it repaired, right? Um
So, I need to understand the world
around me and and update my my internal
beliefs. And so, we'll see the phrase
internal states often times will see it
being replaced with the word beliefs.
Kind of depends on what standpoint we're
talking about, but they are very similar
terms. It can
refer to kind of the same things. It's
just do you want to take a much more
engineering approach to it or do you
want to take more of um
sort of this human-oriented
or human-centered
perspective on it or at least a more
anthropocentric
kind of perspective on it. In that case,
we could say it's kind of like beliefs.
Um
so,
so, to come back to the question, uh
like, yes, the other agents like, all of
you right now in this meeting right now
are sort of other agents relative to to
me as an agent, right? You all are part
of the environment. You all are separate
from me.
And and I'm separate from you and so,
I'm part I am part of your environment.
And so, I have no direct access to any
of your thoughts or beliefs. I don't
know exactly what any of you are going
to do.
I don't know what any of my neighbors
here are going to do.
So, the best I can do is sort of like
use my model of what I think about human
behavior or, you know, for the couple of
you who I've met before, like, you know,
maybe I have certain assumptions
or or or at least certain kinds of
beliefs that have formed through my
experience of speaking with you or
relating with you.
And so, so my model is going to be
composed of this kind of prior knowledge
of the people I do already know, uh, as
well as trying to use knowledge that I
have from other places to maybe guess
what other people are going to to do,
um, or or or how they'll behave or
respond. Or the fact that we're in a
textbook reading group would tell me
like, oh, you all are probably reading
the book or at least considering reading
the book. Uh, at some degree, there's
some relation that you have to active
inference regardless of sort of the
breadth and the the depth of that
relationship, right? Um, so so that was
a very long-winded way of of of simply
saying that, uh, yes, uh,
other agents are
kind of part of the environment. Um,
then the external states would be
internal states of other agents. That's
a little bit
that's a little bit trickier cuz I have
no access to anyone else's
internal states. So everything is an
external state. Um,
like I
excuse me.
Everyone else
is external to me. So so this this this
this the the second half this question
is maybe just a little imprecise in how
it's phrased, but I think it's a good I
mean, I personally welcome these kinds
of questions because that's how we start
to kind of reframe our understanding.
Um,
so
let's see. Discussion about the Markov
blanket made me think if an agent eats
food, does this change the Markov
blanket in the internal and external
states? How exactly? That's a very good
question.
Um, and it relates to a lot of the
things I was already mentioning. I I
genuinely haven't read any of these just
yet, so I'm this is interesting. Uh,
so
I mean in a sense, yes, it's so so
internal states and external states are
kind of always changing. Like for for
many for many living beings to continue
existing, those
their internal states almost like need
to change. If they stay completely
static, um then either A, you have you
have a really good thing going for you
and you're able to just keep doing that
keep doing that in the same exact way as
you always have, great. But um
it depends on what [clears throat] level
you want to look at it. I mean, our
bodies technically need to
continue to do work. They need to
continue consuming calories and and
burning calories and and um
doing work in like the very like kind of
physics terminology oriented sense. So
um and whenever our environment changes
and we need to update our beliefs or
change our internal states or um or
otherwise it's uh so so essentially
we're we're always in flux. We're never
purely static and so we're the
everything is kind of always changing
and the
is it the case that if I breathe in
oxygen, you know, things are changing
and it's like, well, yes, it's it's
helping to regulate my blood blood
oxygenation in my body and a variety of
other things. So um my best answer to
that kind of question would be, I mean,
yes, it's it's always changing and it's
not just eating food um that, you know,
even though that's a a nice example to
just think it through. Um but yeah. Um
does it change the Markov blanket
itself? Well,
in that case, it just depends on how
like what's what's your phenomenon of
interest, you know. Um
in computational psychiatry, I tend to
just think of it as I tend to think of
the brain first. I don't necessarily
think of the whole person first. I think
of the brain first and then I'll think
like, okay, well, but it's the person
who does things and exhibits behavior
that we want to understand." So, I do
want to start extending it there. But,
once I start thinking about like what
are observations coming from the body,
like some of my work has been around
PTSD, um
and sort of understanding symptomatology
of that and potential treatment
interventions. So, uh with that, it's
like what what what does it mean for
someone to start observing that that
they're currently experiencing some kind
of uh set of hypervigilance-related
symptoms. They're having increased um
heart rate and sort of higher uh or
potential hypersensitivity to different
things going on around them. Um
increased um um heart rate, you know,
potential heart heart palpitations at
extreme levels. So, um all those things
are that something that someone observes
from within their own body. In that
case, it's a little bit trickier, right?
Because it's like, well, you want to
view the person as the Markov blanket,
like and they're fully encompassed by
it, but now they're also kind of reading
what otherwise is coming from within
that Markov blanket. So, it's it's a bit
it's a bit tricky. I I I think the main
thing is that we sort of choose
what we want to model. And then it's
there that we kind of draw
the the blanket. Because you can have a
kind of symbiotic relationship with with
many different things. There are old
philosophical theories, like if you pick
up a hammer and you use it, is it not
just an extension of you now? Is it not
just like a new appendage that you've
added to yourself, right? Um but with
the notion of a Markov blanket
specifically, where the idea is that we
can have these kind of if we can clearly
define what are the observations or the
inputs to the agent and what are the
actions or or or the sort of outputs
from the agent. We're able able clearly
define those, then know that the Markov
blanket doesn't it doesn't expressly
change. So, we have a stable picture of
how this works and now now we can model
it. So, if you choose to to sort of
model an agent as, you know, it it one
input to it is that it breathes in air
from from the outside, then that's just
sort of part of the construction of your
your agent, right? So, you now you can
consider that that oxygen itself to like
the oxygen was part of the environment,
but now it has become part of the agent
because that is how we have defined that
that agent.
And then any further philoso- cuz I
realize we're out of time any further
kind of philosophical speculation about
that would be something along the lines
of like, well,
one idea is that an entity whose market
Markov blanket becomes very compromised,
um they like they might dissipate
to entropic forces or otherwise. It
depends on how much of the physics kind
of oriented terminology you want to use,
um but it's sort of like, well, if I
stop maintaining my Markov blanket, if I
stop sort of taking care of of this body
that receives all the observations and
emits all of the actions, uh then over
time I probably will start to kind of
succumb to the environment, right? Uh I
if I stop eating food, uh you know,
there's nothing else out here that's
kind of keeping my caloric intake going,
right? It's just me. Um so so sure, I
will start to sort of dissipate. Um
if um you know, I lose some part of my
my body, then that's no longer part of
my own Markov blanket uh anymore. So, um
yeah, it I
I realize I kind of ended on a bit of a
strange note there, but it's the Markov
blanket concept is very interesting. It
does have some relationship to a lot of
um
Judea Pearl's previous work who who he
had is a kind of a classic in the in the
Bayesian realm and and and mathematics
more generally and I do recommend
checking out um some of his some of his
work or even just doing a good couple
Wikipedia sweeps at least to get a you
know just to be aware of of that. I
think he comes up later in the textbook
um is very useful for thinking about
like a lot of these sort of interesting
like philosophical
uh problems in addition to the maths and
and the engineering. Um so yeah. Um
yeah, I would love to answer more of
these these questions but I think we're
about out of time. So I would just like
to thank everyone for attending. Again,
apologize uh I I apologize that we'll no
longer be offering these these sort of
evening Western Hemisphere uh evening
sessions um but in any case we'll have
two other sessions each week uh to kind
of make up the the difference and
everything will be recorded for you all
to check out. So um so yeah, then thank
you all again and uh I'll see you next
time.